all right so listen yeah you are a
little you're a little
just a little older than me
all right
so i want to know
if
the if the words
up up down down left right left right ba
select start mean anything to you
uh yeah that's uh yeah we're talking
about madden that sounds like madden
no right
that's not mad no okay all right what is
it it is a video game you're you're in
you're in the same ballpark
you know what video is a video game it
precedes you i didn't i i didn't think
you would know it because i don't know
if you grew up on it so people of my
people my age my generation and maybe a
little after we grew up on a game called
contra okay okay contra was on contra
was on regular nintendo and then you had
super contra on super nintendo but i'm
an old school contra guy and contra was
this like this military game where these
two soldiers got dropped in the jungle
and had to fight these aliens oh i
definitely wasn't playing it and you got
all these different guns and you played
as a tandem and it brought it brought
brothers together me and my brother i
was the red guy he was the blue guy
and he used to leave me on certain
boards and make me die but that's okay
uh we we we saved the world quite a few
times in the jungle in contra
reason i bring up contra
it is the original cheat code what i
just gave you okay it is it is the
original because when you entered at the
home screen when you entered up up down
down left right left right ba select
start you went from three lives to 30.
and if you couldn't end contra with 30
lives it was trash i mean you get 30
30 opportunities to get killed by aliens
and if you didn't
defeat contra 30 30 lies so it was the
original people say the cheat code the
original cheat code it was that bouncing
the turtles in mario okay
patrick mahomes
is the walking
manifestation
of up up down down left right left right
ba selection wow
i like you
you can't do anything with this dude
i didn't know where you were going
but i know
it took me it took me a while
he is he is literally playing football
he is playing dudes out there he is
toying with the game he is unfair
he is
jumping up and down
and then throwing the pass
he i mean his fake his fake jump pass
coming come down scramble throwing off
balance
no look underhand
we've seen people with big arms before
michael we've seen people
with athleticism before we've seen
people who combine the two it's the
creativity the imagination the
improvisation
he is
listen man how do you
how do you defend somebody who's not
playing by the rules as a matter of fact
michael he's in the matrix
some rules can be bent others can be
broken i don't even know if that's air
he's breathing i just know there is no
spoon when it comes to patrick mahomes
mike i'm gonna i'm gonna uh
produce a segment right now
that will become a part of brother from
another going forward now we both felt
like we arrived yesterday right
when we saw
franchise mode go across the screen
right yep yep
there's another segment we have to do
called game plan
for a guy like pat you just ask the
question how do you defend that so so
game plan was the best defense in the
league last night
game play patrick mahomes because i
don't know
honestly i don't know how you stop him
now you mentioned i i'm in boston i have
seen
the the the patriots go up against
patrick mahomes multiple times
and they haven't really stopped them yet
now they were able to go to the super
bowl through kansas city but they didn't
stop him if you stop patrick mahomes
it's time sensitive maybe you can stop
them for a quarter maybe you can stop
them for a half as i saw the patriots do
but they still wind up giving up
30-something points
and they won that game because he didn't
touch the ball in overtime i saw i saw
them win a game at gillette stadium
where they gave up 40 points michael
smith and won the game
so
if i'm game planning the kansas city
chiefs i i don't know uh
i guess what i would do
is i'd go back to because there's really
no precedent for it i go back to
peyton manning vintage peyton manning
and i'd say all right he's got edrin
james he's got marvin harrison he's got
reggie wayne what i'll do is i'll try to
take away the receivers and i hope
that
uh that he'll he'll put it in the hands
of the running back and the running back
is not somebody i'm happy to face either
but i'd rather deal with a running
attack
yeah but with people no running couldn't
but he could he also couldn't move like
this because you could have everybody
covered and he will jog for a first down
i mean it's really like you don't have
the answers for him i don't know now
like answering what would you game plan
what would i do i don't know
what would you do you know honestly you
know who it's on and it's
kind of unfair
because
we talked about this yesterday how much
it meant
for lamar jackson
to get a win over patrick mahomes
and we also pointed out as they all do
it's not quarterback versus quarterback
as quarterback versus defense well the
chiefs have an underrated defense or at
least one that was able to give the
reigning mvp fits
and so the way you beat patrick mahomes
sorry to state the obvious is he's got
to be watching you're not going to stop
him if he's on the field
you know you like so lamar jackson had
to be better against the chiefs defense
than he was last night you have to
outscore you have to hope you can
outscore them
or possess the ball long enough to where
they don't score
34 points in their sleep practically
you know so like lamar jackson he said
he said uh that the the chiefs are our
kryptonite first of all i'm glad he said
our
because it might not be an indictment of
lamar jackson individually it may be how
the team is it's defense we talked about
the defense not being able to slow down
patrick mahomes uh the last couple of
years
it may be the scheme
but i wouldn't say that the chiefs of
their kryptonite i would i would say
that a deficit
might be the ravens kryptonite because
they're not they don't seem built to
necessarily come from behind they're a
running team so i would say
i would come back yeah i would say the
chiefs i would say the chiefs are
batman from the dark knight returns when
he put on that armored suit and beat the
crap out of superman or the chiefs are
doomsday and the lead is kryptonite
you know uh to the raven super yeah
um so but the other thing i want to
point out about patreon real quick so we
showed the
though you know him counting we thought
he was counting touchdowns
his fiancee as she tweeted no he's
remembering the fact that the nfl
network had him number four
in the top 100 list
he's listening to people like us
talk about
russell wilson's the best quarterback in
the league he's like number four how he
said he said he's like how am i number
four
but even better now he's motivated
so he's motivated michael he's angry
he's got an edge
he was fourth
but who was first in the nfl network's
poll who i think it was lamar right
lamar jackson jackson right it was lamar
russell wilson and aaron donald that's
why he would bring it out oh four wait a
minute the guy over there like not even
going for 100 yards he's throwing for
100 yards tonight uh and and he's number
one but you know we talked about wink
martindale the ravens defensive
coordinator last week who said hey he's
he's underpaid patrick mahomes yes
that was a good quote but even better
from that same conversation
wink said look
oh patrick mahomes he got a great arm
he can run
he's a handful to deal with
but the other thing is he said he's next
level iq he said this is brady manning
level
of looking at it
so i would say
to answer my own game plan question with
patrick mahomes i say two things you
hope that's not a good game plan hope
but
you hope that they make a bunch of we
wish
we wish
we wish i wish somebody would um
you hope they make a bunch of mistakes
and two
you just
you take away tyreek hill and hardman up
top
over the top
okay just like get back no big plays and
you let everything happen in front of
you
and you hope that you hope that's that's
the plan that's good enough
but really there's nowhere there's
nowhere you can focus you can't just
focus on taking away kelsey because they
got other options you take away tyreek
hill and hartman they got other options
i didn't even mention watkins they got a
good running game
they throw up they throw touchdowns
offensive lineman eric fisher the
underhand touchdowns to fullback so wait
you talking about going back to stuff
and i mean to be a prisoner at the
moment here go ahead but we went on on
patrick and i know we got to go to break
but i want to sneak this last point in
when patrick turned 25 we had a love
fest that was the last time we had a
love fest with patrick holmes and he
turned 25 25th birthday
and somebody posed a question i remember
who it was
because we talked about like oh i know i
know what i ask you i asked you if when
it was all said and done would he go
down as the best quarterback ever
but then somebody asked the question
if he retired now
is he a hall of famer
and i i say no
i still say no
um is he a hall of fame talent
absolutely he's a hall of fame talent
are you see are you putting him are you
putting him into the hall of fame based
on what he could be i'm saying he's one
of the best that i've ever seen do it my
hall of fame michael smith's hall of
fame
is not an accumulation of stats numbers
okay it is not you know it is like are
you one of the best that i ever saw do
it and it's clear at 25 years old he's
already one of the best
most gifted to ever played a position
there are few people
number 12 in green bay comes to mind
there are a few people that make it look
this easy like i said up up down down
left right left right ba select start
that's what you get every time you fire
up the game and maybe your best bet i
got you know what your game plan is for
your defense hit reset what's that start
over
hit reset
you know that's out of here
give me your plans i need a plan
you can't you can't take that in front
of them you can't take that to the
players in front of the meeting room
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports